we've done every form of therapy that
exists
Megan Fox and Machine Gun Kelly are
working on their relationship amid
rumors the two called it quits but a
source tells E.T that the pairs still
have trust issues to work through it's
definitely a process it's not an easy
one
ET Source Says Megan and MGK have a lot
to work out before they can think about
moving forward together as partners MGK
really loves Megan and he is hopeful
that they can get to a better place and
be happy together he knows he is going
to have to go above and beyond to
reconcile things with her our therapist
said that a relationship is basically
the process of breaking each other down
but most people don't have the tools to
build each other back up and so it's a
constant process of like suffering and
passion and love so we're just learning
that and navigating that and doing that
together last month rumors swirled that
the two split after Megan posted these
picks to Instagram alongside cryptic
lyrics from Beyonce's 26 teen album
lemonade well you can taste the
dishonesty it's all over your breath
eagle-eyed fans were quick to notice
that Meg unfollowed her fiance and
deleted all pics from her page before
deactivating her account altogether a
source at the time told E.T that the two
got into a big argument before his
performance at the Sports Illustrated
event in Arizona leading up to the Super
Bowl quote Megan and MGK have a
passionate relationship filled with lots
of intense emotions both good and bad
but after this fight Megan was very
upset following all that the two were
spotted leaving a marriage counseling
office in separate cars after reportedly
spending two and a half hours inside of
course the two got engaged back in
January 2022.
and a source previously described their
complicated Dynamic 2et explaining that
Megan and MGK have had ups and downs
throughout their relationship but at the
end of the day they have a lot of love
for each other and a deep connection
adding that they have very strong
feelings for one another so their
emotions often come out in intense ways
sticking with the journey and crossing
fingers and hoping
at Brian Austin
him and Megan are co-parenting well
together and ultimately just wants her
to be happy Brian also has a 20 year old
son from a previous relationship and
shares an eight-month-old son Zane with
his girlfriend Sharna Burgess he is an
amazing dad now ET Source says Brian is
focused on his newborn this chapter with
Sharna and their own family really
excited uh to to see the Wonder in his
eyes and and the Wonder insurance too
when when she's walking through places
with him and it's really amazing they
are over the moon in love and things
couldn't be better between them
[Music]